Hi.
Today, we're going to do a
really fun problem called
geniuses and chocolates.
And what this problem is
exercising is your knowledge
of properties of probability
laws.
So let me just clarify
what I mean by that.
Hopefully, by this point, you
have already learned what the
axioms of probability are.
And properties of probability
laws are essentially any rules
that you can derive
from those axioms.
So take for example the fact
that the probability of A
union B is equal to the
probability of A plus the
probability of B minus the
probability of the
intersection.
That's an example of a property
of a probability law.
So enough with the preamble.
Let's see what the problem
is asking us.
In this problem, we have
a class of students.
And we're told that 60% of the
students are geniuses.
70% of the students
love chocolate.
So I would be in
that category.
And 40% fall into
both categories.
And our job is to determine
the probability that a
randomly selected student is
neither a genius nor a
chocolate lover.
So first I just want to write
down the information that
we're given in the problem
statement.
So if you let G denote the event
that a randomly selected
student is a genius then the
problem statement tells us
that the probability of
G is equal to 0.6.
Similarly, if we let C denote
the event that a randomly
selected student is a chocolate
lover, then we have
that the probability of
C is equal to 0.7.
Lastly, we are told that the
probability a randomly
selected student falls into
both categories is 0.4.
And the way we can express
that using the notation
already on the board is
probability of G intersect C
is equal to 0.4.
OK, now one way of approaching
this problem is to essentially
use this information and sort of
massage it using properties
of probability laws to
get to our answer.
Instead, I'm going to take a
different approach, which I
think will be helpful.
So namely, we're going
to use something
called a Venn diagram.
Now a Venn diagram is just a
tool that's really useful for
telling you how different sets
relate to each other and how
their corresponding
probabilities
relate to each other.
So the way you usually draw this
is you draw a rectangle,
which denotes your sample space,
which of course, we
call omega.
And then you draw two
intersecting circles.
So one to represent our geniuses
and one to represent
our chocolate lovers.
And the reason why I drew them
intersecting is because we
know that there are 40% of the
students in our class are both
geniuses and chocolate lovers.
OK, and the way you sort of
interpret this diagram is the
space outside these two circles
correspond to students
who are neither geniuses
nor chocolate lovers.
And so just keep in mind that
the probability corresponding
to these students on the
outside, that's actually what
we're looking for.
Similarly, students in this
little shape, this tear drop
in the middle, those would
correspond to geniuses and
chocolate lovers.
You probably get the idea.
So this is our Venn diagram.
Now I'm going to give you guys
a second trick if you will.
And that is to work
with partitions.
So I believe you've seen
partitions in lecture by now.
And a partition is essentially a
way of cutting up the sample
space into pieces.
But you need two properties
to be true.
So the pieces that you cut up
your sample space into, they
need to be disjoint, so
they can't overlap.
So for instance, G and C are
not disjoint because they
overlap in this tear
drop region.
Now the second thing that a
partition has to satisfy is
that if you put all the pieces
together, they have to
comprise the entire
sample space.
So I'm just going to put these
labels down on my graph.
X, Y, Z, and W. So X is
everything outside the two
circles but inside
the rectangle.
And just note, again, that what
we're actually trying to
solve in this problem is the
probability of X, the
probability that you're neither
genius, because you're
not in this circle, and you're
not a chocolate lover, because
you're not in this circle.
So Y I'm using to refer
to this sort of
crescent moon shape.
Z, I'm using to refer
to this tear drop.
And W, I'm using to refer
to this shape.
So, hopefully, you agree that
X, Y, Z, and W form a
partition because they
don't overlap.
So they are disjoint.
And together they form omega.
So now we're ready to
do some computation.
The first step is to sort of
get the information we have
written down here in terms
of these new labels.
So hopefully, you guys buy that
G is just the union of Y
and Z. And because Y and Z are
disjoint, we get that the
probability of the union is the
sum of the probabilities.
And, of course, we have from
before that this is 0.6.
Similarly, we have that the
probability of C is equal to
the probability of Z union W.
And, again, using the fact
that these two guys are
disjoint, you get this
expression.
And that is equal to 0.7.
OK, and the last piece of
information, G intersects C
corresponds to Z, or our tear
drop, and so we have that the
probability of Z is
equal to 0.4.
And now, if you notice,
probability of Z shows up in
these two equations.
So we can just plug it in.
So plug in 0.4 into
this equation.
We get P of Y plus 0.4 is 0.6.
So that implies that
P of Y is 0.2.
That's just algebra.
And similarly we have point.
0.4 plus P of W is
equal to 0.7.
So that implies that
P of W is 0.3.
Again, that's just algebra.
So now we're doing really well
because we have a lot of
information.
We know the probability of Y,
the probability of Z, the
probability of W. But remember
we're going for, we're trying
to find the probability of X. So
the way we finally put all
this information together to
solve for X is we use the
axiom that tells us that 1 is
equal to the probability of
the sample space.
And then, again, we're going
to use sort of this really
helpful fact that X, Y, Z, and W
form a partition of omega to
go ahead and write this as
probability of X plus
probability of Y plus
probability,
oops, I made a mistake.
Hopefully, you guys
caught that.
It's really, oh, no.
I'm right.
Never mind.
Probability of X plus
probability of Y plus
probability of Z plus
probability of W. And now we
can go ahead and plug-in the
values that we solved for
previously.
So we get probability of X plus
0.2 plus 0.4 plus 0.3.
These guys sum to 0.9.
So, again, just simple
arithmetic, we get that the
probability of X is
equal to 0.1.
So we're done because we've
successfully found that the
probability that a randomly
selected student is neither a
genius nor a chocolate
lover is 0.1.
So this was a fairly
straightforward problem.
But there are some important
takeaways.
The first one is that
Venn diagrams are
a really nice tool.
Whenever the problem is asking
you how different sets relate
to each other or how different
probabilities relate to each
other, you should probably draw
Venn diagram because it
will help you.
And the second takeaway is that
it's frequently useful to
divide your sample space into
a partition mainly because
sort of the pieces
that compose a
partition are disjoint.
So we will be back soon to
solve more problems.